ROBERT KUBIS: With almost
500 session at Next 2018,
it's understandable that you
couldn't get to them all.
So if you didn't see
Google Cloud Storage--
Building Systems with Security
by Design and Default,
then stay tuned because
here's the rewind.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
With Google Cloud
Storage, you have access
to a planet-scale blob storage
system with a simple interface.
When moving your company's
data into the cloud,
security is of
utmost importance.
That's why it's critical
to understand and enable
key security systems
inside Google Cloud Storage
to make sure things stay safe.
Let's talk about some things
that Google Cloud Storage does
to keep your data
secure by design.
First, our private network--
users' data enters and leaves
Google's private network
at a point of presence
closest to them.
This results in better
performance, cost savings,
and security because data is
traversing Google's network
with encryption in flight and
has the least possible exposure
to public internet.
Second, encryption is supported
as a first-class citizen.
Data in Cloud Storage
is always encrypted
at rest with several layers
and in flight via SSL/TLS
by default. This is no choice.
On top, we allow you to
supply your own encryption
keys as well just in case
you need more control.
Third, we support
comprehensive auditing.
This is especially important
in highly regulated industries.
Things like cloud audit
logs, access to storage
logs, and Stackdriver monitoring
can help your application
with any compliance
[? stance ?] you may have.
Finally, integration
of Data Loss
Prevention, or short, DLP, which
allows you to redact, encrypt,
and desensitize personally
identifiable information
in your data and get a very good
grip on your data via analytics
and visualization.
Now Google Cloud Storage aims
to be as secure as possible.
But even with that, there
are some key patterns
that you can use to ensure
your security regulation even
further.
One is to properly separate
privileged access to your data.
Sharing your data through
the right [? hoops ?]
and right people is a
constant and ongoing concern.
As such, it's good practice
to use Google Key Management
Service, or short, KMS,
to define storage access
permissions to groups
of individuals.
Secondly, we use that same KMS
to help encrypt data at scale
for [INAUDIBLE].
For example, rather than sending
files with sensitive info
to KMS before storing
them, which wouldn't scale,
files are encrypted using
a local encryption key,
and then simply use KMS to
manage that key over time.
Third, it's important to
understand the right way
to delete your data
in a secure manner,
and this one is a tricky one.
As your data moves
through your system
for various types
of analysis and use,
it's getting proliferated.
As deletion comes
around, you want
to delete the entire
footprint, which is harder
to track down than you might
think and could take some time.
To solve this quickly,
you can once again
use Key Management Service.
Rather than deleting
the data, you
can simply delete the
key used to encrypt it,
which effectively renders
the data meaningless.
And then clean up later,
remove the unused data
as a form of garbage collection.
The last [INAUDIBLE] is about
preventing deletion of data
for regulatory purposes.
In some scenarios,
you can revoke access
based on policies to
lock the data for you
a certain number of
seconds or up to years
and then give
access back to you.
For more suggestions
on security,
as well as some awesome
demos and announcements
about upcoming features, and
to learn what Google Cloud
Storage has in common with
Jacques Cousteau and scuba
diving, check out the full
talk listed in the description
below.
And don't forget to subscribe
to the Google Cloud YouTube
channel for more
Next Rewind content.
Thank you for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]